it takes real grit to put yourself
forward for election yet politics is the
alternative to Anarchy or despotism we
are blessed here to take it for granted
thank you also to my agent and to my
family thank you above all to the people
of Rochester and strewed you are my boss
I step down to ask your permission to
join you Kip you hired me again you
remain my boss don't let me forget it
thank you to to the many conservatives
who came with me to my new party thank
you to the Lib Dems who came thank you
to those who did not vote before
including first-time voters in their 70s
thank you to to the labor voters who
switch to you kit with me in such
numbers I say to you that the radical
tradition in Britain is a noble and
high-minded one it is the tradition that
took power away from the elites and
spread it amongst the people it's the
tradition of Levellers Chartists and
suffragettes it is the tradition that
gave us appointment on merit Gladstone
e'en finance universal suffrage
religious freedom and racial tolerance
it is the tradition about which I spoke
in my maiden speech in Parliament I'm
not sure if I'm allowed a second but if
I were I would say that the radical
tradition which has stood and spoken for
the working class has found a new home
in you Kipp as Labour represents those
comfortable at the top of the public
sector it is not Ed Miliband but you Kip
that represents the concerns of most
working men and women
thank you to the thousands from UK who
gave up your time to campaign for me I
wish I had the words to express how
grateful I am
this is your victory as you savor it
think of this Rosharon strewed was our
270 first most winnable seat if we can
win here we can win across the country
if you vote you Kip you get you kid
so how did we win here by earning
support from every section of the
community from students and from
pensioners from professionals and from
unemployed people from people of African
heritage recently moved from the
southeast London and from those who made
the move long before from Sikh and
Muslim communities and many Commonwealth
backgrounds people in Medway cherish
Britain's links to distant fast growing
continents we want to lift our eyes to
horizons beyond Europe we are linked by
commerce and kinship by language and law
by habit in history to the wider
english-speaking world and what we're
about it
however doubting watching journalists
and opposition activists maybe I had
more than a dash of support from people
who came here from other EU states
people who feel patriotic about their
adopted country people attracted by our
strong economy our open society and a
better future many have come to Britain
because of the opportunities we offer as
we create more jobs than the rest of the
EU put together and because of what
makes our country special they are now
here as part of our community and they
will always be welcome if you Kipp is to
win nationwide and we've proved tonight
that we can it must do so on that basis
we must be a party that speaks to and
for the whole nation and everyone who
lives within it
whichever constituency you live in
whatever you'll form a party allegiance
think about what it would mean to have a
block of you keep MPs at Westminster
large enough to hold the balance of
power if you believe in freedom if you
believe in low taxes if you believe in
clean government if you believe in
localism if you believe in people power
if you believe that the world is bigger
than Europe if you believe in an
independent Britain then come with us
and we will give you back your